hey folks this is jake decker reading
for reviewer richard wakeling it's been
nine years since saints row 4 was
released pitting the 3rd street saints
against an alien invasion that featured
superpowers time travel matrix-style
simulations and the complete destruction
of earth where do you go after a game so
ridiculous and outlandish after a period
of absence rebooting the series sounds
like a logical next step and that's
exactly what developer deep silver
volition has done with this new stripped
back saints row
[Music]
it's still not realistic by any stretch
of the imagination but it's slightly
more grounded however you still
shouldn't envisage finding many of the
modern trappings of open world games for
as much as saints road differentiates
itself from the bombast of its past few
entries it still closely resembles a
game from the same era leading to an
experience that often feels stale and
dated for the most part this isn't
something you could level at saints row
4's approach to freedom around character
identity and gender and this is carried
over into the rebooted saints row the
character creator lets you design pretty
much any person you want there's a broad
range of prosthetic options various
types of vitiligo a number of sliders
for body options that do away with
binary gender selection a choice of six
distinct voices and the ability to make
an asymmetrical face to name just a few
of the available options you can also
hop back into the character crater at
any point and change your entire look
this sounds like an insignificant
feature but it isn't always a given and
speaks to saints row's focus on
inclusivity you can create a character
that represents you or simply delve into
some of the more eccentric customization
options and devise a creation with a
metal skin demonic eyes and glowing red
hair there are already some fairly
accurate recreations of shrek being
shared just to give you an idea of how
exhaustive the process is
once you've finished creating your ideal
gang boss you're thrown into a story
centered around four young friends who
share a dingy apartment and commit
crimes to try and make rent saints row
adopts an anti-capitalist stance and
touches on some socially conscious
issues throughout the first few hours
with characters bemoaning their
crippling student debt and lack of
health insurance while also taking a
satirical swipe at toxic corporate
culture alluding to these issues makes
the cast somewhat relatable but it
doesn't take long before you're building
a criminal empire and discarding these
topics in favor of more outlandish
endeavors while the main character is a
self-described murder machine the rest
of your friends are well-rounded and
avoid falling into a pitfall of
homicidal archetypes the perpetually
shirtless kev for instance is obsessed
with food and music regularly talking
about the kitchen appliances he hopes to
buy when he's not busy djing a party
nina on the other hand is a mechanic who
loves restoring classic cars but also
has an appreciation for art and an
interest in gallery curation then
there's eli the strategist and
aspirational entrepreneur of the group
he's averse to violence but spends his
off hours larping in the desert and
shooting like-minded individuals with
foam bullets the heart of saints row has
always resided in its characters and the
dynamic and playful banter between the
friendship group is a highlight of the
story they may be violent criminals but
they're the kinds of people you wouldn't
mind hanging out with and provide a
bright spot in an otherwise unfulfilling
narrative this
is where all our dreams come true don't
say that my dreams are pretty weird the
overarching plot is fairly boilerplate
and plays out as you would expect it's
anticlimactic too as most problems are
solved with relative ease adversaries
are simply dealt with and more than a
few loose ends remain unresolved after
the previous two numbered games in the
series were imbued with such creativity
it's disappointing that the storytelling
in this reboot is so humdrum while the
story does touch on some modern social
trends the gameplay feels dated much of
saints row feels like a throwback to
open world design of a decade ago it's
third-person shooting is adequate but
it's tough to get a good feel for the
aiming when playing on a controller the
reticle is always slightly too finicky
even after fiddling with the sensitivity
settings to try and find a sweet spot
it's something i grew accustomed to over
time but the best way to approach combat
is by making liberal use of the auto
aiming assistance that locks on the
targets when aiming down sights this
makes it easier to execute headshots and
trigger the satisfying splat that
accompanies them
and that's how it's done
the arsenal of weapons at your disposal
is rather lackluster however there's the
usual assortment of pistols smgs and
shotguns but there's little reason to
deviate from the starting assault rifle
the inaccuracy of the smg only compounds
the game's awkward aiming and the
shotguns feel decidedly weak and are
irritatingly slow to fire an issue when
most enemies soak up damage the base
assault rifle excels in any situation so
it quickly became my go-to for a
majority of the game especially since
neither of the upgrades for it were all
that appealing due to their slow rate of
fire fortunately the addition of
whimsical skill moves do spruce up the
combat quite a bit
by completing missions and earning
experience points you level up along a
linear progression path where each level
unlocks a new skill move you can assign
up to four at once and utilize them in
combat by killing enemies to accrue the
flow points you need to activate them
these points fill back up relatively
quickly so it's unlikely you'll ever be
left waiting for a chance to use one of
these skills the first one you unlock
lets you grab an enemy and stuff a
grenade down their pants before heaving
them back towards their buddies which is
especially useful for crowd control on
top of just being fun to do other skills
range from a powerful flaming punch to
an anti-gravity device that launches
enemies into the air and leaves them
defenseless the standard weapons are
lacking but these skills add some much
needed variety to combat that shake up
the familiar routine for the most part
these skills also incentivize you to
push the attack and mix it up in combat
and this is something the game factors
into its health system your health bar
is divided into separate chunks your
health will automatically recharge if
you don't sustain damage for a few
seconds but it will only refill to the
nearest checkpoint whether that's
one-third of your health two-thirds of
your health and so on to get more health
back you need to kill enemies by getting
up close and performing a stylish
execution
can only use these cinematic takedowns
once before the ability needs to charge
but kills recharge the meter much more
quickly so you're encouraged to create
mayhem in order to better heal yourself
there's no cover system only a role that
can help you avoid fire so combat is all
about staying on the front foot and
being aggressive to survive it's at its
best when things are frantic and you're
overwhelmed by enemies converging on you
from all sides this happens more often
on higher difficulties but the
checkpoints in campaign missions are so
forgiving that the trade-off doesn't
seem worth it when not shooting people
most of your time is spent behind the
wheel of various vehicles driving in
saints row feels overly floaty but this
was never a hindrance to my enjoyment of
cruising around the city there's a
dedicated drift button that lets you
swerve around corners with ease and the
addition of a side swipe attack makes
vehicular combat more exciting
having to shoot and drive at the same
time has never felt good in these types
of open world games so being able to
shunt cars off the road and watch them
explode in a fiery blaze is a marked
improvement on what's come before it
helps of course that the fictional city
of santa elesso is so visually appealing
mixing towering skyscrapers with quiet
suburbs and large swaths of desert set
in the united states southwest it calls
to mind such places as albuquerque and
reno while being distinctly its own you
can see the influence of mexican culture
in some of its architecture and the
beautiful murals adorning certain
buildings while the neon lights of its
casinos cast a senior vibe it's a shame
then that the city doesn't produce the
emergent action that would give it life
this goes back to the game's archaic
feel where you spend much of your time
simply driving back and forth between
missions
a significant part of saints row's
campaign revolves around various
criminal ventures once your startup is
up and running you can purchase these
ventures to generate more income and
gradually grow your business you start
off with a car dealership before being
able to acquire a restaurant laundromat
toxic waste disposal service and more
obviously each one is a front for
illicit activity and it's your job to
help out with that side of the business
you need to steal food trucks full of
drugs for the chupacabra restaurant for
example while the car dealership tasks
you with jacking specific vehicles
around the city these missions initially
seem optional providing you with another
avenue to earn some cash before long
however your progress through the
campaign is gated by missions that
require you to have purchased and
completed a number of these criminal
ventures i always had multiple missions
available so it never felt like this
halted my progress the main issue is
that these ventures are decidedly milk
toast each one usually involves driving
from a to b with only minor variations
between them sometimes you're being
chased other times you have to avoid the
police by dodging their big red circles
on the minimap either way it's a lot of
driving from point to point over and
over again and it doesn't take long to
become tedious some of the ventures
offer a little variety like the clothing
brand that asks you to take pictures of
different materials or the medical
clinic where you commit insurance fraud
by throwing yourself into moving
vehicles the latter has been featured
throughout the series before and is the
best of the bunch the rest are just
bland
the traditional story missions add more
impetus by engaging an action movie
hijinks but the mission design still
feels like a relic of the past one early
mission sees you assaulting a convoy by
leaping from car to car to make it up
the line this sounds like an exciting
set piece but in practice you're just
shooting static enemies before watching
a short cut scene of your character
making an untroubled jump these missions
are still enjoyable at times but there's
always this nagging feeling of deja vu
because it all feels so familiar even
when its creativity shines it's a
letdown on the gameplay side
[Music]
one of the criminal ventures you can
purchase involves eli's mad max inspired
larping exploits these missions are
combat focused and stand out because
everyone is committed to role playing
your previously violent executions now
consist of fake punches and pretend
chest bursting and your arsenal is
replaced by toy weapons that fire foam
projectiles later on there's a giant
cardboard worm that knocks people over
with its roar and an excellent
recreation of the greatest death scene
in movie history i loved everything
about this questline except playing it
despite all of these changes combat is
very much the same only you're forced to
use bad weapons that take twice as long
to kill people saints row has a lot of
good ideas but it restricts itself by
not being ambitious enough from a
gameplay perspective it's also worth
noting the open world jank that comes
with the territory there's everything
from characters that appear as floating
heads to npcs getting stuck in walls
broken vehicle physics and enemy ai
falling apart to the point where they
don't realize you're there for the most
part these are minor oddities that don't
significantly hamper the game but i also
ran into a few more serious issues
during one mission the scripting failed
and left me trapped with no door to go
through while restarting the nearest
checkpoint caused the game to crash
there was another instance where a
vehicle i had to destroy was
indestructible and a few other cases
where a mission wouldn't progress
saints row reigns in the absurdity to a
fairly significant degree but still
manages to indulge in some of the
chaotic action and silly hijinks the
series is known for its story is simple
and fairly predictable yet spending time
with its diverse and well-rounded
characters makes it worth seeing through
to the end it's a shame the gameplay
isn't quite as progressive opting
instead for out-of-date mechanics and
level design combat is decent and story
missions are enjoyable when at their
most over the top but there's too much
bland filler between rebooting the
series made sense yet in many ways
saints row is still stuck in the past
and struggling to live up to its legacy